je me suis rapproché tous ces bons
secrètement et tout à coup j'ai
découverte et écrivent éléphants de mes
batteries c'était mon stylo un stylo qui
écrit tout seul
une araignée mangeuse de menteries ou un
arbre à saucisse tous sont le fruit de
l'imagination des élèves de saint
quentin en yvelines
ils étaient douze à présenter leurs
menteries lors d'un concours au prisme
mais au fait c'est quoi une menterie qui
est un mélange de vérité mensonge et
humour tu date est vraisemblable sauf la
fin moi j'ai trouvé faire réduire
pasquet qui doivent on doit avoir de
l'inspiration
organisé par le réseau des médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines depuis
quatre ans ce concours a réuni cette
année plus de 250 élèves seuls quatre
élus ont été récompensés par le jury
mais raconter ça menteries devant un
public est déjà une grande victoire
le but c'était vraiment d'apprendre aux
enfants à écrire à inventer et ensuite à
passer de l'écrit à l'oral d'abord avec
le support texte mais ensuite d'aller
sur scène sans supporter ex est vraiment
de raconter ce qui est complètement
autre chose
et pour arriver à ce résultat ils ont
été accompagnés par le conteur etienne
il n'y a jamais de mauvaise idée il ya
jamais de mauvaises écrit à il ya des
choses intéressantes partout donc
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus c'est aussi
de les mettre en confiance parce qu'un
beau jour ils vont se retrouver face à
un employeur face à un jury d'examen
face à un guichet pour demander quelque
chose et s'exprimer prendre la parole
c'est très très très important les 150
menteries seront restitués dans un livre
dans les médiathèques et sur le site hi
média thèque de saint quentin en
yvelines à découvrir avant que
l'araignée mangeuse de menteries ne les
dévore